hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to darkest dungeon now I've
played this before but only the early
early demo in fact this is a new version
that was worked on by the same guy that
made joy of creation Nixon or at least
he worked on part of it or a lot of it I
think he did the animation for this one
but either way this is the new dark
deception never mind I got that wrong
dark deception dark deception it is done
now my faith lies in darkness okay I
don't know if that's the best place for
it but okay oh hello how are you
dears oh hi hello how are you I suppose
yes I'm kind of already here I don't
know if I need to come any closer I just
got here oh yeah okay I can't deny that
one okay so many good intentions late
toys yeah it sounds about right okay all
right well you don't have to hit the
nail too hard on the head there no I
don't like this dominatrix thing that's
going on I'm not into that so if we
could just get on by that before before
something awakens in me that I don't
want to okay you've got potential I see
it in you and I can help change your
fate okay but if you want a new life
you're going to have to suffer quite a
bit I don't know if I want that that
doesn't sound good
also are you the announcer from Team
Fortress 2 are you is this like your
moonlight job just being creepy kind of
vampire lady going on tell me I'm not
big enough fine then but room Bierce is
but you're tall what is my wish I don't
even know what my wish is
okay why did I come here in the first
place I'm sorry that I'm only eye level
with your boobs clock's ticking hang on
let me get a look at this amazing
architecture that you got in here love
the heavy this statue it's awfully nice
hey don't look at me like that at all oh
god I thought your head was gonna turn
all the way around oh it's so pretty
why am I here all right okay I'll go
into this man they really revamped this
crazy okay I don't know if that was yawn
or you're just surprised that I came
close I don't like it
oh that's do I owe you one blue one blue
one blue when believe humbly ah now
that's what I call a door or a lack of
door that's what I call a hole in the
wall okay
boy they beat this game up good hello
monkey business oh I remember the
monkeys oh I remember the monkeys in
beat indeed yeah a little bit here you
are you being all meta about the
original game because that's pretty cool
ring for service hello service I don't
know why you'd pop out if he's gonna
walk out like an elevator or something
like that
alright parently nothing welcome
breakfast and murder free until 10:00
a.m. so it cost money after 10:00 a.m.
do I have to pay for my own murder oh
you are you are a bag
why did that scare me you are a [ __ ]
that didn't scare me there's no evidence
to the contrary what are you gonna do
the same don't you even think about it
no no well this is an odd predicament
but I'm gonna go blindly forward hello
friend how are you doing good to see you
I'm sorry I startled you friend okay
ah Bing bong no all right then well that
was fun I'm glad I did that I'm glad we
all agreed that that was worth my time
I'm glad that I'm here oh wait ah
perfect my ride cause this hop on end
even though I was gonna go down wink
wink wink wonk
I don't like it what have you got
oh here's a statue our life crystal yes
oh no those soul shards fragments of
human spirit scattered throughout the
halls of this little maze each crystal
is a remnant of one who has met their
end here gather them all and the first
ring piece will be yours oh yeah you'll
need this it can detect each shards
location hmm it was left by the last
guest to disappoint me here Oh we'll
listen lady listen lady listen ladies
construction break those boards and
let's get this party started if there's
one thing that I don't do its disappoint
I am the master of undisciplined a tion
people always be satisfied when I walk
in the room it's like I do not try to
get not
satisfied challenge when I'm around okay
so I gotta be somewhat organized about
this I remember what I played this
before why is that happening
that is a bucket not bad shard streak oh
yeah yeah user bad fight wait whoa whoa
hey whoa nany nany nany nany nany nany
nany nany de I mean they really beefed
this up
they beat for this up a lot I thought I
could get that one there they didn't
stab me in the face they chewed my face
off there's a big difference lady
Woodson if you want to get satisfied by
me whoa oh I got a big Blanco
alright then who's this let me in let me
in please okay so it's an enemies were
revealed but I don't see no enemies
what's the point of that oh that's not
good
that's not good that's not good that's
not good okay it's fine there is the
enemy but I don't know how long it's
gonna be revealed like that oh this is
where i wills you can't catch me you can
catch me oh you can catch me oh you oh
oh you can catch me oh boy how long are
the enemies gonna be revealed for cuz
that's awfully handy Pope pop I'm
warming up hope I'm warm oh well this
doesn't sound good
I wanna get a good look at ya get a good
oh I don't like the look at ya I don't
like to look at you guys why to see how
you look or you're a charming fella
ain't ya
oh you're full of spunk ain't ya well
alright you take care now you have a
good one I know it's closing in I'm
aware of this oh where am I now
well I have no enemies revealed which is
probably a bad thing that's a lot of
okay well I'm did
dad already that's okay nobody liked you
anyway hey don't feed into my
insecurities like that I think that
people probably like me a lot my god
this is gonna be difficult but there's
gotta be difficult cuz they're coming to
get me oh I went the wrong way
I'm full of dick and piss and vinegar
yeah I'm so stupid
bad mark pickle dummy Miam Miam big dumb
okay that's fine
I made it somehow hey yo ii yo homie no
oh there was no one coming down that way
I thought that was turns out that well
is not oh oh oh that's too close for
comfort
oh yeah yeah II know bad touch
what is this I hope it's good I got it
enemies stunned yeah aw stupid you
forget I'll stupid on you huh you is too
stupid to come get me stupid why you be
so dumb you dumb stupid huh you're full
of stupid and dumb you all oh wait no
are they not stupid are they not dumbed
you're dumb and you stupid
you dumb and stupid and dumb full of
dumb me I'm smart big smart with my big
brain oh here they come
can I get another powerup that beat that
be so nice okay I'm in trouble if I get
cut off down this corridor for some
reason oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh we know they were probably coming
yeah that was very close okay we're good
we're far away from them now it's all
Gucci baby all Gucci all day oh you
think you got me the answer hey I'm on
fire okay that's good that's good
I'm gonna get this I'm gonna get this
and then I'm gonna get you oh you think
you got me you don't not mean not today
not me not today not me not today
not me not today it's so funny to see a
game with with like kind of a a little
bit of a silly premise I mean it is it's
a game a pac-man
what a terrifying game of pac-man at
that but it's funny to see a game like
this come into a really really nice
remake into it and I mean this is free
[ __ ] back
no thank you you bribe I'm oh yeah
you're I think they might be pissed off
at me oh yeah they're pissed off well
off [ __ ] oh oh god oh I have no idea
where that is okay those are the last
four I imagine I gotta get those and
then I gotta get all the way back to the
entrance but thankfully I'm close to the
entrance looks like I planned this out
playing sound with my big brain where
we're please don't cut me off don't cut
me off don't cut me off no don't cut me
off I said please please be open path I
am so fine I am fine yes go why who
dares I dare I
I'm trying where's the portal hey hey
listen
listen buddy I don't know who are you
talking about right wait whoa whoa whoa
Oh Bing bong that was a little
unnecessary you think mr. monkey man Oh
again I don't know who this lady is and
I don't know what she has to do with
this guy let's be stove holy [ __ ] I
think there might be some kind of an
escape Mortal go through the portal and
you ain't gonna get mortal no more oh I
escaped that was nice I was nice secrets
secrets secrets downloaded patootie Oh
level 2 what does that even mean
I don't even know what that means but I
got a lot of soul shards that's a lot of
people that died in that place but I got
him oh hey hey Bierce
you doing you so fierce Pierce oh you
fierce Pierce I like you for your
spirits with your fierce necklace your
friends kind of a douche don't mean it's
all hello hi hi nice eye she's just
using give her the ring and there will
be consequence
okay now Who am I gonna trust the
horrible disembodied veiny eye or the
very nice attractive lady now the nice
attractive ladies who seem to not be too
concerned with my death are always to be
trusted and I don't trust no door I
never trust a door with an eye on it I
wouldn't suffer from the monkeys but
yours can I bet your powers have so much
reach now yes ma'am yes ma'am it's been
so long
well that's okay I think muscle memory
kicks in after a while the demons power
is contained inside it the creature of
infinite cruelty that you
just Malik
all right the ring and you can use
Malik's power to fulfill your darkest
desires
so the legend goes you wouldn't happen
to have use this ring at some point
which you have have done that have you I
guess you might have yes then yeah eat I
suppose hello lady my god
more pieces together are you ready for
another nightmare
oh yes aids wait but there's but there's
ten portals my god you are stunning lady
I am so okay there's a weird yawn thing
again I am so into you also hey demon
guy how are you doing you okay I don't
like that you know I'm going to enjoy
watching you suffer all right well you
keep watching pervert weirdo are you
doing lady all right well anyway Bierce
hey listen you know I'd do anything for
you and I mean anything anyway so I'm
gonna go on this boat oh we asked fry
fine yes go for it let's see what
happens it's cool I hate it I hate it I
hate that no it's all done no I can't
believe that that's but you know
actually thankfully I think I'm okay
with that because whatever I'm looking
at in front of me right now is horrible
this is great I can't believe they'd
turn a concept like this into something
really amazing lejeune
no thank you oh god no oh my god no back
my god Oh Bierce is Diaries oh hell yeah
oh but also Vince livings Nick Nixon
Sita yeah
Daniel Coe Peter Anderson Vince livings
shun Kim Penn livings Gabe Lopez Melissa
Sawicki seats a Vilma Marcus Williams
URI de loca all these wonderful people
thank you so much for working on this I
can't wait to see what comes next
because this is some good stuff you've
got here and the first part was free I
imagine they'd probably charged
something for this game because this is
really nicely made so hopefully it gets
fully made sometime soon so thank you
everybody so much for watching you can
check out the game in the description
below and as always I'll see you
[Music]